summarization of data is still important
perhaps summarization not down to a
single scale of value but looking at
that whole C of of numbers you have to
find
patterns like what is inflation in a
particular sector what is it maybe uh
change over time maybe different
geographical regions you know the things
of that nature I think that's kind of I
don't know even what that task is uh you
know that's what you could look at
machine learning you can look at AI with
that perspective which is like how do
you represent what's happening
efficiently
as efficiently as possible that's never
going to be a single number but it might
be a compressed model that captures
Something Something Beautiful Something
fundamental about what's happening it's
an opportunity
for sure right um
you know
if we take
um for example during the pandemic
the the response of the political
apparatus was to lower interest rates to
zero
and to start uh start buying Assets in
essence printing money and the defense
was there is no inflation yeah
but of course you had one part of the
economy where it was locked down so it
was illegal to buy anything
well you couldn't you know it was either
illegal or it was Impractical
so it would be impossible for demand to
manifest so of course there is no
inflation on the other hand
there was instantaneous immediate
inflation in another part of the economy
for example
um you lower the interest rates uh to
zero at one point we saw the uh the swap
rate on the 30-year note go to 72 basis
points okay that means that the value of
a long dated Bond immediately inflates
so the bond market had hyperinflation
within minutes
of these uh financial decisions the
asset Market had hyperinflation we had
uh what you call a k-shaped recovery
what we affectionately call a shake
k-shaped recovery Main Street shutdown
Wall Street recovered all within six
weeks
the inflation was in the assets like in
the stocks in the bonds uh you know if
you look today you see that uh typical
house according to the case Schiller
index today is up 19.2 percent year over
year
so
if you're a first-time home buyer the
inflation rate is 19 percent
the formal CPI announced a 7.9 percent
you can pretty much create any inflation
rate you want by constructing a Market
Basket right a weighted basket of
products or services or assets that
yield you the answer
I think that
you know the fundamental failing of
economists is is first of all
they don't really have a term for asset
inflation
right what's an asset what's asset
hyperinflation you mentioned bond market
swap rate and asset is to where the all
majority of the hyperinflation happen
yeah what's inflation what's
hyperinflation what's an asset what's an
asset Market I'm going to ask so many
dumb questions in the conventional
economic world you would you would treat
inflation as uh the rate of increase in
price of a Market Basket of consumer
products
defined by a government agency
so that they have a like traditional
things that a regular consumer would be
buying the government selects like a
toilet paper food toaster refrigerator
Electronics all that kind of stuff and
it's like a representative a basket of
goods that lead to a Content existence
on this Earth for regular consumer they
Define a synthetic metric right I mean
I'm going to say you should have a
thousand square foot apartment and you
should have a used car and you should
eat you know three hamburgers a week now
10 years go by and the apartment costs
more
I could adjust the Market Basket by a
you know they call them hedonic
adjustments I could decide that it used
to be in 1970 you needed a thousand
square feet but in the year 2020 you
only need 700 square feet because we've
miniaturized televisions and we've got
more efficient electric appliances and
because things have collapsed out of the
iPhone you just don't need as much space
so now I you know it may be that the
apartment costs 50 percent more but
after the hedonic adjustment there is no
inflation because I just downgraded the
expectation of what a normal person
should have so the synthetic nature of
the magic allows for manipulation
by people in power pretty much like the
I guess my criticism of Economist is
rather than embracing inflation
based upon its fundamental idea which is
the rate at which the price of things go
up right
they've been captured by uh mainstream
conventional thinking to immediately
equate inflation to the
government-issued CPI or
government-issued pce or
government-issued PPI measure which was
never the rate at which things go up
it's simply the rate at which a
synthetic basket of
products and services the government
wishes to track go up now the problem
with that
is
two big things one thing is the
government gets to create the Market
Basket and so they keep changing what's
in the basket over time
so I mean if
if I keep trying if I said three years
ago you should go see 10 concerts a year
and the concert tickets now cost two
hundred dollars each now it's two
thousand dollars a year to go see
concerts
now I'm in charge of calculating
inflation so I redefine you know your
entertainment quota for the year to be
eight Netflix streaming concerts and now
they don't cost two thousand dollars
they cost nothing and there is no
inflation but you don't get your
concerts right so the problem starts
with
continually changing the definition of
the Market Basket but in my opinion
that's not the biggest problem the more
the more egregious problem is the the
fundamental idea that assets aren't
products or Services
assets can't be inflated with an asset a
house
a share of Apple stock
um a bond
um any a Bitcoin is an asset
um or a Picasso painting
so not a consumable good not a uh not
not not an apple that you can eat right
if I throw away an asset
then uh I'm not on the hook to track the
inflation rate for it so what happens if
I change the policy such that let's take
the classic example a million dollar
Bond at a five percent interest rate
gives you fifty thousand dollars a year
in risk-free income
you might retire on fifty thousand
dollars a year and a low-cost
jurisdiction
so the cost of social security or early
retirement is one million dollars when
the interest rate is five percent
uh during the the crisis of March of
2020 the interest rate went on a 10-year
bond went to 50 basis points
okay so now the cost of that bond is 10
million dollars
okay the cost of Social Security went
from a million dollars to 10 million
dollars
so if you wanted to work your entire
life save money and then retire risk
free and live happily ever after on a
fifty thousand dollar salary living on a
beach in Mexico wherever you want it to
go
you had hyperinflation the cost of your
aspiration increased by a factor of 10
over the course of you know some amount
of time in fact in that case that was
like over the course of about 12 years
right as the inflation rate ground down
the asset traded up but the you know the
conventional view is oh that's not a
problem because it's good that that
assets it's good that the bond is highly
priced because we own the bond
or um what's the problem with the
inflation rate in housing being 19 it's
an awful problem for a 22 year old
that's starting their first job that's
saving money to buy a house but it would
be characterized as a benefit to society
by a conventional Economist who would
say well housing asset values are higher
because of interest rate fluctuation and
now the economy's got more wealth and uh
and so that's that's viewed as a benefit
so the
what's being missed here like the
suffering of the average person or the
uh the struggle the suffering the pain
of the average person
like metrics that captured that within
the economic system is that is it when
you talk about why do I just say it is a
conventional view of inflation as CPI
understates the human misery that's
inflicted upon the working class and and
on uh mainstream companies
uh by uh by the political class and so
it's a massive shift of wealth from the
working class to the property class it's
a massive shift of power from the free
market uh to the centrally governed or
the controlled Market
it's a massive shift to power from the
people to the government and and maybe
one one more illustrative Point here
Lexus
is uh what do you think the inflation
rate's been for the past hundred years
I will be talking about the scalar again
if you if you took a survey of everybody
on the street and you asked him what do
they think inflation was uh what is it
you know
you remember when Jerome Powell said our
Target's two percent but we're not there
if you go around the corner I have uh
posted the deed to this house sold in
1930.
okay and uh the number on that deed is
one hundred thousand dollars nineteen
Thirty and if you go on Zillow and you
get the Z estimate is it higher than
that no 30 million five hundred thousand
dollars yeah so
that's uh 92 years 1930 or 2022 and and
in 92 years we've had 305 X increase in
price of the house now if you actually
about calculate you can you come to a
conclusion that the inflation rate was
approximately six and a half percent a
year every year
for 92 years
okay and and there's nobody
nobody in government no conventional
Economist that would ever admit to an
inflation rate of seven percent a year
in the U.S dollar over the last century
now if you if you uh dig deeper I mean
one one guy that's done a great job
working on this is safety and almost who
wrote who wrote the book the Bitcoin
standard and he notes that on average it
looks like uh the inflation rate and the
money supply is about seven percent a
year all the way up to the year 2020
if you look at the s p index which is a
Market Basket of scarce desirable stocks
it returned about 10 percent
if you talk to 10 a year for 100 years
the money supply is expanding at seven
percent a hundred years
if you actually talk to economists or
you look at the the economy and you ask
the question how fast does the economy
grow in its entirety year over year
generally about two to three percent
like the the sum total impact of all
this technology and human Ingenuity
might get you a two and a half three
percent Improvement a year as measured
by GDP
is that are you okay with that I'm not
sure I'm not sure I'd go that far yet
but I would just say that
if you had the human race doing stuff
yeah and if you ask the question how
much more efficiently will we do the
stuff next year than this year or how
what's the value of all of our
Innovations and inventions and
investments in the past 12 months
you'd be hard-pressed to say we get two
percent better
typical investor thinks they that
they're 10 better every year so if you
look at what's going on really when
you're holding a million dollars of
stocks and you're getting a 10 gain a
year you really get a seven percent
expansion of the money supply you're
getting a two or three percent gain
under best circumstances
and another way to say that is
if the money supply stopped expanding at
seven percent a year the s p yield might
be three percent and not ten percent it
probably should be
now that that gets you to start to ask a
bunch of other fundamental questions
like if I borrow a billion dollars and
pay three percent interest and the money
supply expands at seven to ten percent a
year and I ended up making a 10 return
on a you know billion dollar investment
paying three percent interest is that
fair
and who who suffered so that I could do
that because
in an environment where you're just
inflating the money supply and you're
holding the assets constant it stands
the reason that the price of all the
assets is going to appreciate somewhat
proportional to the money supply
and the difference in asset
appreciations is going to be a function
of the scarce desirable quality of the
assets and to what extent can I make
more of them and to what extent are they
are they truly Limited in Supply